so these are the documents that I've
been shown and like you say the source
that showed them to me said that they
believe them to be a hundred percent
authentic Sky News hasn't independently
been able to verify this we've gone to
the Iranian and the Russian Embassy here
in London but they haven't yet come back
to a response without to us with a
response but I have gone to some other
experts and they believe that these
contracts are plausible and they also
say the date on the contract here the
14th of September last year that also
corresponds with other reporting of this
kind of transaction taking place and in
terms of what it actually allegedly
shows this contract appears to be for a
load of samples of different types of
ammunition for artillery pieces and for
tanks
um it's worth about a million dollars
it's written in English which I'm told
is apparently customary when it comes to
Iranian contracts with other countries
this bit is a supplement to an alleged
related contract it's also for
ammunition pieces it's worth 750
000 roughly but as well as that it
includes the barrel of a gun for a tank
and also for an artillery piece and
experts have said it's quite interesting
these kinds of bits of equipment
um that Russia is apparently seeking
from Iran would suggest would point to
Russia running out of weapons as part of
this war okay and what's been happening
in the war overnight well there's been
some quite significant developments
overnight with the Russians claiming
that they've just thwarted a um an
offensive by the ukrainians in the
Donetsk region
um saying that they've claiming that
they've killed some like 250 Ukrainian
personnel and destroyed tanks there's
been no word from the Ukrainian side
this is an information War as much as
anything else and the last time Ukraine
launched a counter-offensive a major
counter counter-offensive last August
into September it was incredibly careful
about the information that was being
released it didn't say anything it was a
big blackout along the front line and so
you can imagine this time a similar
tactic being used as they attempt to
ensure that these weapons they've been
given by the West so they're getting
supported by the West in contrast to
Russia of course and the training
they've been given can be used to to the
maximum effect so it should become
clearer what's going on in the coming
days